Uh Hey Guys um
Im Currently make-uped-up with MatPat
Mattpat: Heeyyyyy
Mark: Heyyy uh
subscribe to me not him >:3
(Matpat laughs)
Um anyway so... Matpat: You can subscribe to me
though like *stutters* Pity subscribe... pity subscribe
yeah don't do that... Anyway so
We're here on a big set, and um
and if it's not obvious there is a lot of, um
are we even allowed to talk about this?
I have no idea
Matpat: We're allowed to talk about it,
but we're not allowed to reveal any wide shots
of the field or who wins. (mark: swag swag swag)
(Mark: swag swag swag)
Matpat: squad goals!
Matt Patt: Squad goals
Mark: This is like the, this is like the designated- squaggles?
what does squaggles mean?
Matpat: Squad Goals
Mark: Ohhhh
I thought you said squaggles
#squaggle
These are, uh, called hard foam weapons
So what you have is something that
looks a lot like Iron
I think this is an actual prop from the movie
You can hit yourself on the- ow that actually hurts
Matpat: Markiplier educational blog
Mark: You can-
Matpat: ow geez
Mark: See I just said that it hurt!
Matpat: And then you proceeded to hit me over the head with it!
Mark: Well you need to experience it with me
if you're gonna be in a video (Matpat: It's nice)
Mark: I happen to get hurt in a lot of videos that I make
Mark: it's really bizarre.
Matpat: Hey, we suffer for our art!
Mark: Art.. Shut up.. You pretentious prick!
Matpat: [laughs]
Mark: Make another FNAF video ya asshole!
[Both laugh]
Mark: There is more shit here
Wheeeee!
Oh and I'm in my swag-gear
So, swag, swag, swag
Okay, anyway
f-f-f fuck you
Matpat: Brilliant
This is the BTS guy. He's been following me around like a creeper, and now
Hi, oh, behind the scenes ception, oh my god-ha-ha-ha
Yeah, my objective here is to just ruin all of his shots.
ahh, my finger!
[Matpat and Mark laugh]
Matpat: That's how Markiplier lost a finger.
Yeah, exactly. I won't be able to hit the D key anymore.
Matpat: That's it.
Mark: I can't turn right i'm not an amdi turner anymore. [both laughing]
Matpat: You just like circle, left turns all the time.
[Mark laughing]
Okay so I'm over on the Horde side now, and, um,  you can tell it's stupider,
it's just rocks and dirt, and a whole bunch of other crap, and um... the weapons are cool though.
Hey what's up?
Jordan: What's up?
Mark: I'm here with Jordan, uh, I thought originally he was on the opposite team so I called him a fucking loser, right as soon as he walked in the door,
um... I haven't changed my mind about that but he's on my team so, he's going to be a-
Jordan: So you've got a fucking loser on your team.
Mark: Yeah, you're going to be on the front lines I'm going to have you leading the vanguards, [Mark laughing]
Jordan: You're gunna have me in the back throwing rocks at people, go here!
Mark: Yeah, I wanna take -
Mark: There's a throne on the Horde side, and I want to drag it onto our hill and just sit by the flag all relaxed; go my subjects, please attack.
Jordan: You've got to get a bow and arrow, or a crossbow.
Mark: Well we got-
Jordan: Firing down on people.
Mark: Well, we got-well, we're not actually murdering people at least as far as we know.
Jordan: Oh, well that what I signed up for.
Mark: Yeah well, I mean, I thought so too, you know. I mean, they're not human, they're Horde right?
And that's the only thing that matters. Jordan: Exactly.
[Mark laughing]
Mark: That's where the disgusting reality of Markiplier sets in, how horrible of a person I actually am.
[Everyone laughing]
(Laughs)
Okay so, uh, if the alliance wasn't badass enough as it is
they equipped us with stylish fanny-packs
(Ammo, ammo packs)
Mark: No, fanny-packs!
to hold our ammo, so we're gonna be doing wonderfully
They get shoulder pads!
SHOULDER PADS!
Woman in background: Okay everyone, can we please have quiet on the set!
Woman in background: We will be rolling sound, thank you! Rolling sound right here so please keep the volume down, thank you everybody!
man in background: they're just waiting for you to start filming
Mark: *whispers* FUUU-
Yo yo yo what up it is your main man Markimoo swag 29
Woman in background: Let's circle up everybody, can we circle up over here
Jordan: You're like Michael Fassbender, you should be the assassins creed Trailer that I haven't seen or something.
Mark: Thank you, my biggest secret is that I'm actually am Michael Fassbender
Jordan: Are you?
Mark: so thanks for revealing that to everybody involved
Jordan: I'm so sorry I've ruined it all for you
Mark: Yeah you ruined it all
Jordan: I don't think I've ever worn all white in my entire life before, this is the first-
Mark: You've never worn PANTS in your entire life before so you can't-
Jordan: No, I have.
I actually wore pants yester-, no the day before yesterday.
Mark: Yeah?
It's *stutters* it's a monumental occasion and that's why I remember
Mark: I'll look into your camera and you look into my camera
[Both laugh]
Jordan: This is so weird!
I don't even know if I'm pointing it correctly!
Mark: HEY!
*whisper* ok we gotta go
Mark: *wurgh*
Yo, we're bout to rock it
in the *stutters* game of the century
Man on right: The flagger dome
Mark: Whatever this game's called, for warcraft
Man on left: Shout out your youtube channel
Mark: Yeah, shout your youtube channel!
Man on right: youtube.com/---
Mark: Ignore him, subscribe to Markiplier!
[men in back laugh]
Markiplier's the one!
Man on right: betrayed by my team captain!
Mark: I want all of you to vlog and say 'subscribe to Markiplier'
that's a requirement
Man on right: I say that every vlog anyways!
Mark: Thank you!
Man on left: Every video!You gotta do it!
Mark: Every video! subscribe to Markiplier, whatever, it's cool
Man on right: It just gets dubbed over, youtube.com/(says in deeper voice)MARKIPLIER
[all laugh]
Mark: Yeah
Mark: opposing team, they're probably gonna win
I mean, we're not playing to win here
other team member: Dude I apo- Our team is throwing sooo much shade at your team I apologise
Mark: Well I don't care!
It's cool, like we're gonna win because the people watching are gonna be-
We're the heart of the champion, you gotta rise above the hate, it's understandable right?
other team member: I mean you guys all get used to the hate so I understand
Mark: Yeah it's understandable, I mean we're huggers, we believe in like, caressing people
We're gonna give a few gentle kisses you know?
other team member: Well you're the captain, you got any inspirational words for your team?
Mark: I just said it.
We're gonna hug 'em, we're gonna embrace 'em close, y'know, show love not hate
we're gonna be embracing all the enemies, it's gonna be totally fine, it'll be cool
Hey, I'm with my true brothers. If they win,
I was encouraging all along because, red hair obviously.
Unfortunately I was made team captain of the Alliance
and we're obviously gonna lose, like that's just a given, like when can we win
woman on left: I'm glad you accept this now
Markiplier: Yeah, so it's gonna be cool. We're gonna pull up a show,
everyone's gonna shoutout, y'know subscribe to markiplier and it's gonna be great
Matpat: You should subscribe to markiplier
Mark: Should subscribe, really-
Matpat: It's a pretty good channel. I-It's up-and-coming
Mark: Yeah, and don't worry I'll make sure we lose. I'll make sure we lose, yeah.
Subscribe to PewDiePie - he's a cool.. He needs it - REALLY needs it
Mark: Ha Ha Ha
Mark: Don't worry, I already conceded, so it's ok, it's alright
I told em we were gonna lose
Philip: We gotta just like dip your head across like the corner -
- and they'll be like: "Oh it's a teammate" and then just *RRRGGHH*
Mark: Yeah, exactly. Yeah, sneak up behind em, that's the whole strategy, WINK
Ok I'm uh.. I'm kinda done, um..
I won't tell you who won
because I can't, since this video's coming out tomorrow
but it was..
a frickin' war.. it was an endeavor-
what the frick is going on with my face
Jordan: There were casualties all over the place, not everyone made it out alive
Mark: It was bad
Jordan: blood
Mark: Oh man. I dodged a lot of balls
and, I got hit by a few more, so y'know
deuces
subscribe to Markiplier
ah fuck